the Obamacare compromise that two
senators reached this week has hit some
major obstacles Republican Lamar
Alexander and Democrat patty Murray made
a deal to maintain Obamacare insurance
subsidies and give States more
flexibility but several key Republicans
now say they will not support it
president Trump originally called the
plan a very good solution for the short
term but the next day the president
tweeted he could never support bailing
out insurance companies Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill with the latest on this
story Nancy good morning good morning
senators Alexander and Murray are going
to formally unveil their bill on the
Senate floor today even though the White
House now says that the president
doesn't support the deal in its current
form this is a deal that aims to
stabilize the individual insurance
market by reinstating subsidies for
insurance companies to bring down the
cost of coverage for two more years this
is after the president said he'd hoped
those payments last week a number of top
Republicans cast out against the plan
yesterday Speaker Paul Ryan said the
Senate should keep its focus on repeal
and replace of Obamacare and Utah
senator Orrin Hatch called for a
long-term solution not a short-term fix
now
that might make it seem like this deal
is already dead but keep your eye on
December 8th on the calendar that's when
Congress needs to pass the next
government funding bill or risk a
government shutdown Republicans are
going to likely need Democratic votes in
order to get that bill passed and so
folding this healthcare deal into that
spending bill might be the best way Nora
to get Democratic support it might also
make the health care deal a little less
radioactive for Republicans all right
we'll be watching and say thank you so
much